that i will go to
distance in your eyes
[Music]
i set it up
[Music]
that's me in the corner
that's me in the spot like
losing my religion
[Music]
oh no i've said it too
laughing i thought that i heard
[Music]
i'm choosing my confessions
try and keep my eye on you
like a hurt lost oh no
i said too much
i set it up
consider this consider
[Music]
brought me to my knees
[Music]
[Music]
i thought that i heard you laughing
i thought that i heard
that was just a dream
that was
[Music]
trying to keep up with you
and i don't know if i can do it
i'm now sad too
much
[Music]
[Music]
that was just
was just a dream just a dream
[Music]
just
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th president of the united states
donald j trump
who gave
[Music]
there ain't no doubt i love this land
god bless the usa
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of
from texas down to houston
and new york to venela
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
who died who gave
[Music]
and defend her still today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
wow that's so great
i want to start off by saying a very big
hello wisconsin it's great to be with
you
and i'll also say this i have never
spoken where i had so many people behind
me
i have a whole state in behind i want to
just thank everybody this is a great
turnout they wanted a bigger space they
got a bigger space
because seven days from now we are going
to win this state
and we are going to four more incredible
years
in the white house thank you
this election is a choice between a
trump
super recovery or a biden depression
that's what you're going to have with a
raise of taxes
the biggest tax increase in our history
is ridiculous
it's a choice between a trump boom or a
biden lockdown let's lock it all down
and by the way speaking of lockdowns
let's get your governor to open it up
let's get him to open it up it's a
choice between our plan to cut
your taxes or even and i have to tell
you you know we've given you the biggest
tax cut in the history of our country
you know that
biggest regulation cut in the history
of our country and sleepy joe biden
his plan is to raise your taxes at a
level
that our country has never raised taxes
before
somehow that doesn't work too well do
you agree
i don't think so i don't think so i've
never heard of it before but that's okay
you can't hear of everything right all
my life i've watched people want to cut
taxes
is a guy who's he's running on a basis
of let's raise everybody's taxes
next week wisconsin's going to answer
the call of history
once again we had a great victory here
did we have a great remember that four
years ago
he said donald trump has won the state
of wisconsin it's been a long time since
a
republican did that but we're actually
much higher
now than we were then we have a campaign
that's actually more enthusiastic
and that was i would say that had to be
number one in history four years ago
but you know what this is going to be
the most important election
in the history of our country because
you see what's happening
the radical lefts and you're going to
defeat
biden and dark money donors and corrupt
special interests
one of the most important issues in this
election
is law and order we say it flawed order
joe biden and his party incite violence
and hatred against our police officers
and we're not doing that
no we're not doing that remember the
debate the first debate i said which one
did you like better the first one or the
second one
jesus both that's a fed he said the man
my man is there
uh yeah did anybody see the last one
anybody watching
seems to have had a very big impact we
learned a lot about him he's uh
number one he's against oil gas
probably likes wind but wind is very
intermittent
let's watch the president tonight on
television i'm sorry darling the wind's
not blowing
last night philadelphia was torn up by
biden supporting radicals
30 police officers philadelphia police
officers great people
they were injured some badly biden
stands with the rioters and i stand with
the heroes of law enforcement
and you know what they can do their job
very easily just
let them do their job the biden harris
plan would end
cash bail you know they want to have
cash bail so everyone just walks around
no matter what they do ends cash bail
free 400 000
dangerous criminals it would slash
police budgets all over the country
it would tie the hands of every police
officer in the country and they would
appoint anti-police prosecutors in
every community in america i don't think
that's for wisconsin we know each other
well
biden is soft and weak and too scared to
be proud he doesn't want to be president
let's face it
[Applause]
you know you got his bad body language
there's a lot of bad but his man knows
body language better than any man i know
it's
that's a lot of bad body language from
joe you know he got out yesterday
you saw that because we're making
speeches all over
pennsylvania he got out and he got out
of delaware and
he said what's the closest point to
pennsylvania it was just a few
minutes from his basement
and he went and made a speech and that
was a mistake because they had to take
him off the stage because they didn't he
didn't know where the hell he was right
that didn't work out too well no because
he had a lid you know like a garbage can
you put it
in the can it's a lid it's called a lid
but he doesn't want to be present one
thing about this job you gotta want it
and you gotta want it this is tough this
is fun
and doing this i don't usually say it
but i say it doing this
and unlike biden who's made a fortune in
politics what a fortune
the press is not allowed to write about
that though
but biden made a fortune you know what
this has cost me billions of dollars and
you know
i could not be happier because we have
done things
that nobody else could have done in the
first three and a half years
there's been no administration that's
done what we've done in the first three
and a half years with our military with
our vets
with regulations with cutting taxes
biden's running mate the most liberal
member in the u.s senate
she makes bernie sanders look like he's
a conservative
even urged their supporters to donate to
a fund
to bail out rioters in minneapolis where
they had such problems until
the national guard went in and they
stopped it would you say that was about
what 22 minutes it was all over
including an attempted cop killer they
wanted to bail him out
the policies will set cop killers free
we believe if you murder a police
officer you should get the death penalty
and i know you're a state that
believes you murder a police officer
you saw a month ago the two young
officers sitting in a car
and the guy comes up now you do that
stuff and
you can't get away with it when the
violent mob came to
kenosha do you know kenosha everybody
know kenosha
biden opposed sending in the national
guard we sent in the national guard
and we saved kenosha we saved kenosha
kenosha wouldn't be standing right
and i got a lot of credit thank you to
the sheriff and so many others for their
support
they've actually came out and supported
me and thank you very much where's the
sheriff is he around you someplace
what a hell of a show thank you very
much that's great
i appreciate you that's the first time
you ever did it
i appreciate it thank you very much
fantastic
good man good man it took generations to
build
the america that we know and love but if
the radical left gained power it would
take them only a matter of months to
burn it down
tear it down or destroy it i'm the only
one standing between you and the left
wing mob i hate to tell you there aren't
too many of us
but we're standing in your second
amendment and many other things right
[Applause]
biden has not only declared war police i
mean you know it really is my father
taught me a long time don't use the word
cops
because the word cops that's a little
slang always call on police
so i never use it you know i see cops
but
sometimes it's not bad sheriff let me
ask you cops or a police or doesn't it
matter if it's done with a heart who
cares right
right if it's done with the heart so
like i said
he declared war on the cops
and uh it's not working out too well
you're gonna see something you're
gonna see a giant red wave
on tuesday
you're gonna see a red wave like they've
never seen before and they saw a very
big one i'll tell you what they got a
glimpse on
four years ago because that was i
remember they said where did these
people come from
where do they come from they're great
americans they don't want anything they
just want that level playing field and
they came out and they voted
and this is going to be bigger this is
going to be bigger and they know it
they know it they know it they don't
like to report it they see what's
happening
they see what's happening mike don't
they huh they get it
it's going to be very big and it's going
to be beautiful
and it's probably going to start it
doesn't have to start on tuesday
it could sort earlier early voting you
want to be there you know these ballots
you see was i right about the ballots
it's messed up like you wouldn't believe
now they say we'd like to
get the ballots and maybe get them
within a few days of the election
and we'll take 10 days to count them up
oh good let's let the whole world wait
while you count your ballots and you
know what happens while they're counting
them
they're dumping more ballots in there
okay where they where did they come from
now they have to we had a great ruling
right here we had a great ruling right
got that yesterday supreme court said
nope that's your date that's it's called
november 3rd that's your date right
[Music]
but sleepy joe declared war on american
workers and biden spent the last 47
years
outsourcing your jobs you got hit hard
opening your borders
you don't have borders you don't have a
country and sacrificing american blood
and treasure in
endless foreign ridiculous wars
countries
most of you including even most of the
people
they never even heard of these countries
we're bringing them all back home you
know that right they're all coming back
home
afghanistan iraq keeping some in syria
if you don't mind we're keeping the oil
you know they should have done that
they should have done that with iraq
remember i said don't go into iraq
but if you go and at least keep the oil
we need to keep the oil
baidu is a cheerleader for nafta and
china's entry into the world trade
organization
he repeatedly tried to slash medicare
and social security
he's a uh shill in a sense for foreign
countries
you got to take a look at this guy's
record of course right now he has no
idea where he is that's a
that's a time that's an entirely
different problem
that's a very big different problem but
who the hell look we have to say it like
it is
hey we have the greatest country in the
world and we have potential like no
country has
and we can't play games we can't play
games
we can't and besides that he's not a
nice guy okay just so you know he was
never a nice guy so i feel better
he was a nice guy i wouldn't say
thank you very much thank you decade
after decade
biden twisted his knife into the back of
wisconsin workers but workers throughout
the united states
you don't have to take my word for it
for a special group of people
the people of wisconsin i spent a lot of
money on this crazy video look at this
and you're going to see it i hope the
people back here can see it can you see
it do i hope
oh that's terrible
all right you'll take my word for it go
ahead play
my problem is i voted for them i'm
supporting nafta
because i think it is a positive thing
to do and i do not pretend to be an
expert on
international trade matters trade
agreements like nafta and permanent
normal trade relations with china which
forced american workers
to compete against people making pennies
an
hour has resulted in the loss of 160 000
jobs the president is absolutely right
when he says that china has been
cheating for 25 years
and that bill clinton didn't do enough
about it george w bush didn't do enough
about it barack obama didn't do enough
about it rising china
is an incredibly positive development
for
not only china but the united states and
the rest of the world
rising china is a positive positive
development
it is in our self-interest that china
continue to prosper
we want to see china rise china is a
great nation
and we should hope for the continued
expansion china is not our enemy
we talk about china as our competitor
we should be helping the idea that china
is going to eat our lunch
it's bizarre
they're not bad folks folks china's not
a problem
allowing china into the world trade
organization which he supported
extending most favored nation status to
china which you supported
that those steps allowed china to take
advantage of the united states
by using our own open
trade deals against us no do you think
in retrospect that you were naive about
china no
but doesn't he deserve some credit for
that it's better the usmca is better
than that
it is better than nafta
[Applause]
never said i oppose fracking you said it
on tape
i did show the tape put it on your
website i'll put it on put it on the
website
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including
coal and fracking in a biden
administration
no we would we would work it out we
would make sure it's eliminated
i guarantee we're going to need foster
fuel
no more no new fracking i'd gradually
move away from fracking
and i think it's critically important on
day one that we end
any fossil fuel leases on public lands
what about say stopping crashing and
stopping pipeline infrastructure
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking i have one final
would he close down caroline or would
you close down the
other way i would transition from the
oil industry yes
oh transition in terms of business
that's the biggest thing because
basically what he's saying is he is
going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you remember that
pennsylvania
now to be fair maybe biden's not telling
us
because he's forgotten his own plans
watch biden's staff quickly swoop in to
shuffle him along during a quickie
escape the basement trip to pennsylvania
here's the deal one of the things that
that is important
is that
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
uh
i think that was terrifying
what kind of country we're going to be
four more years of george
georgia he uh going to find ourselves in
a position where
if trump gets elected we're going to be
we're going to be in a different world
that was yesterday that was all
yesterday so that took place yesterday
every day we could put up another treat
the whole thing is ridiculous
the whole thing you know until the
plague came in from china i didn't even
have a race
and then it came in and we did a great
job we saved millions of lives 2 million
lives 2.2 million it was supposed to be
and this guy you know he didn't see oh
don't ban it
you're xenophobic right don't ban china
don't ban china this is in january
or very early on very very early
everybody said don't ban i'm not blaming
anybody but they all said don't bend i
said
it's a heavily infected country it's
starting from there
i banned china then i banned europe with
all of the problems they were having
with spain and italy and france and
everybody
and i banned i banned europe and
two and a half months later he was
saying no man and then
he runs for president he lucks out
because pocahontas decided to stay in
so she took a lot of votes away from
bernie not too many she didn't do too
well
but she took enough away that he ends up
winning on super tuesday right
and all of a sudden i got this guy
running and
he starts complaining that i should have
moved faster but he was two and a half
months behind
and i said that's going to be hard to
explain but i have to explain it to
people
one thing nice is when you put this
thing up here it saves you a lot of
words right
it saves you a lot of words and then the
other thing remember for a year
we will not frack now it affects you
because of your energy costs and all of
the things that affects everybody
we're right now energy independent it's
a great thing first time
but it really affects can you imagine
texas pennsylvania the different places
ohio so many places
so many places north dakota can you
imagine
taking texas i mean he's against oil
he's against guns and he's against
religion
right other than that he's wonderful
he's just perfect
and then they say it's a very close race
in texas
i don't think so you're against
you're against oil guns and god
you don't have a close race in texas i
don't think but they said it the same
thing four years ago
that texas is too close to call it's
going to be a very very tough race for
donald trump that it was donald right
now they call me president out of
respect i'm chef of the office
it will be a very very very tough race
i mean the polls have closed in texas
donald trump has won the state of texas
it was like all or one thing
they don't do that unless you have a
landslide so we had like and now they do
the same thing
again well this time at least they say i
have a little lead
how can you have a little lead when i'm
the oil person
we needed to fire up your factories and
you
just we can't they don't even know how
to do it
they have like aoc plus three
they say okay we'll get rid of all
fossil fuels we have a problem in
wisconsin we're doing very well we have
a lot of factories we have a lot of
plants
how are we going to fire him up she has
no clue
she has no clue i don't even think she
studied it
it may be in high school she studied it
but probably not in college
did she go to college tell me did she
because i don't know
i don't know her background but it is
not heavy into the environment
all of a sudden she comes up with the
green new deal
and these people all did because they
have to because the radical left
wants them the green new deal will cost
100
trillion dollars if we have a hundred
perfect years the greatest years of the
history of our country
we can't make it with a hundred trillion
spent on the green new deal
in 2016 wisconsin voted
to fire this corrupt political
establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally putting america
first
[Applause]
[Music]
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician
it's one of the reasons i was elected
i was a politician i probably wouldn't
have been elected right
if i don't always play by the rules of
washington and the washington
establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i'm fighting for you
harder than any president has ever
fought for you
[Applause]
together we'll continue to fight for
american workers support
our police defend our second amendment
which is under siege but don't worry
about it
don't worry about it it's fine but it is
under siege
secure our borders and you know the wall
is up to
over 400 miles right now we have very
secure
over four we're gonna have it finished
very soon they don't talk about it
anymore you know
they used to go he will never get it
built because that was like
you could the democrat party was so
against it
they said it was obsolete use drones so
we could watch everybody
pour into the border right let's send a
drone up there great
walls and wheels right walls and wheels
never get obsolete there's about the
only two things i know of that don't get
obsolete everything else is obsolete
about 15 minutes after you figure it out
and ensure more products are proudly
stamped
with that wonderful beautiful phrase
made in the usa
right we will deliver record prosperity
epic job growth and a safe vaccine that
eradicates the virus
and quickly ends this pandemic
and you know with the fake news
everything is covered kovit kovetkova i
had it
here i am right i had it
first lady had it baron had it but baron
had it for about 12 seconds
young young immune system young
no it's uh covered you turn on the news
cover
coven you know when they're going to
stop talking about it so much
november 4th you're right
november 4th oh it's a whole crazy thing
i mean it's too
complicated to explain these people are
very corrupt very dishonest but they got
a lot of problems
on november 4th you'll hear we're doing
extremely well
and you'll see you'll see you know they
used to always say that europe look at
europe look at europe
well first of all they count their cases
totally differently but look at your
well they have a big spike and you know
what it's going to go down
and we had a spike in miami we had a
spike in texas
arizona it's all way down to very low
numbers
but i'll tell you all they want to talk
about is covid
but the good news on the fourth they'll
stop talking you watch
they'll stop talking you get out that
red wave
just get out we have to win this
election this is the most
important election we've ever had we
can't let this radical left socialist
group take over and i've been saying it
now for a long time because i see it
there's this
inclination by a group of people
our country will never be a
socialist nation we will never become
a socialist nation normal life will
fully resume that's all we want is
normal life seven months ago right
we had the greatest economy in the
history of our country
everybody was doing well best numbers
we've ever had
and next year will be the greatest
economic year
in the history of our country you see
what's happening you see how it's being
built up
and by the way i'd love to do stimulus
but crazy nancy doesn't want to do it
she wants to get bailout money for her
democrat-run
states that are high crime and doing
badly
and i spoke for wisconsin when i said no
thank you
nancy have a good time we'll get big
stimulus right after the election's over
hopefully we can take back the house to
be nice get rid of her
get rid of her speaker we'll get kevin
in there kevin would be good you know
who kevin is kevin mccarthy
if biden and the democrat socialists are
elected
they will bury your regular you know
what's going on right
with your regulations i've got your
regulations down to a level
but we can go further we have statutory
requirements we're going further
they'll bury your really your family and
yourself in regulations
terminate religious liberty dissolve our
borders indoctrinate our children
with that really bad stuff that they
want to teach in schools
which we've largely ended but it can be
started again and destroy the suburbs
beyond repair
suburban women you're going to
love me you better love me
did you see 60 minutes the other night i
always joke i say
suburban women i'm getting rid of that
regular you know there's a regulation
that essentially destroyed the suburbs
okay it would have you know who was in
charge of it who would have been
cory booker good luck corey he's another
beauty he's another we deal with some
real beauties
but we had a regulation where they can
build low-income housing and projects in
in a neighborhood near you you know
right in a neighborhood near you
in the suburbs right so the fake news
was saying
we think that donald trump is having
problems with
suburban women i said why because i'm
going to stop
crime from going to the suburbs because
you know antifa
and the anarchists they view the suburbs
as next that's what they would like
right
so the suburban woman wants law and
order they want safety
and they don't want a regulation that's
going to destroy the
suburbs and then i listen to these
people talk about how
so four years ago they talked about the
same thing they said
women will not be voting for donald
trump
and then after about four hours and they
declared total victory for trump
you know they said he cannot get to 270.
he cannot this was in the afternoon
he can and for about six months before
that by the way
didn't just start in there donald trump
cannot get you need 270 right cannot get
to 270.
he cannot get and they were right we got
306.
well we picked up a place called
wisconsin that helped
that wasn't that wasn't high on the list
of victories
now it is but we're just now it just
came out we're leaning by like three
points that's good
they won't report they won't report that
they'll look at 30 polls
they'll look at 30 polls some of them
are totally fake some of them are sickos
right
they look at polls where they interview
38
democrats 21 republicans i said that
doesn't sound like too fair to me
and they'll say trump is down by five
well if i'm down by five
when they're doing 38 to 21 that means
i'm winning in a landslide what kind of
polls are these
no seriously what kind of polls are
these these people are crazy
joe biden will delay the vaccine
postpone
therapies prolong the pandemic shutter
your schools open your schools please
bankrupt your small businesses and shut
down our country he will destroy our
country
and by the way the cure cannot be worse
than the problem itself i said that a
long time ago
except when i originally said it i had
no you know i felt it i felt it was bad
i just felt it was an instinct
it can't be worse than the problem
itself so the shutdown
with alcoholism with drugs with abuse
with suicides with all the things that
happen
it's worse you can't do this you got to
get your governors to open up
there's there aren't many of them there
aren't many of them now
but you gotta now one of the reasons
this is another one on
or we'll go to the fourth right november
4th they'll be announcing
we're opening our state so one of them
stupidly like three weeks ago now
we think we're going to open probably
around november 4th how about that
genius okay
no they'll all be open around a couple
of days after the election
biden even wants to lock down young and
healthy americans
yet for those under age 50 the recovery
rate
is 99.98 think of that
99.98 and for school kids it's slower
than you know it's better than that
biden's cruel and census lockdowns
would cause countless deaths from
suicide and from all of the problems we
have
and we would have problems and economic
people lose their jobs they lose their
jobs
their small businesses go out or they
work for small businesses or big
businesses that go out
we're going to open up our states we've
got to tell your governor we've got to
open up
our states does anybody like your
governor do you like him
okay let's have who likes the governor
is he going to win reelection
who does not like the governor
all right it's interesting
lots of luck governor you gotta open up
now a lot of governors that did this you
know michigan she the only one that was
allowed to
go around and roam was her husband right
he was allowed to go fishing and
sailing nobody else was there to stay
locked up in their house but we won a
supreme court case against them
they found it unconstitutional that she
locked down
the state of michigan i just left
michigan i gave a speech
in 32 degree weather in the rain
and they're great people they're strong
people so i said you know what i'll do
i won't put on a hat okay and i'll just
stand there in iran
and i'll freeze it i'll make a speech
but i'll tell you there was such love it
was incredible we're winning
we're winning michigan too no no we're
winning i had a nice hat i was gonna put
it on
and they were waiting for four or five
hours i mean i said i feel so guilty i
mean i was on time but they get there
very early
like probably some of you you got here
very early right
all these front rowers i know got here
i know the front rowers get here very
early
i mean we have it where they get three
four days in advance they
were you here three four days
[Music]
i know i will you vote you promised you
voted for trump right now
she's great now we have great people
we've never had
and four years ago we had the most
enthusiastic campaign
anyone's ever seen probably there ever
was
this this campaign and i never thought
i'd say it
has more enthusiasm more support
than we did four years ago
because you know four years ago i was a
business guy i was successful i was very
successful i came
and i said i was going to do all right
get it out of your system
so four years ago i came and i saw trade
i probably trade was the
you know it just drove me crazy losing
all our factories closing all our
factories
they're moving to mexico they're making
it in china they're doing all these
things a lot of people
a lot of places moved up to canada you
know canada was very tough on us
but a lot of i saw this that's probably
the main reason i ran
but i saw it all happening it was so
easy to see i saw it all happening
and that's probably the main reason i
ran but four years ago i was just saying
i'm going to cut your taxes i'm going to
cut regulations i'm going to rebuild
your military i'm going to do all the
things i
said and actually i did more because
like space force we opened up space
force i never said i was going to do
that
i learned that after watching russia and
china and everything else i learned that
after i was here but i never took
one of these people right back there
said he may be the only politician that
actually did
more than he promised during the
campaign i believe that's true
so we have so we have actually more
enthusiasm
because i did everything i mean i said
the wall the wall was about i mean the
wall was just a very expensive
the border patrol wanted a certain way
very expensive very i mean they're right
they wanted vision they wanted steel
they wanted rebar they wanted
concrete inside and they said
you know what i'll do it i want to do it
the way you want it i don't want to give
you any excuses
for doing a bad job in the border gee if
he only would have built the wall right
but all of the things that i said i did
everything i said i did and that gives
this campaign more energy than a guy
that was successful that said
hey i'm going to do a lot of things
because you've been hearing that for
years from politicians
and they don't do it they don't get the
job as i said about biden the other
night at the debate
joe you're all talk and no action and
it's true
and i'd look at him and say joe why
didn't you do it you're not saying well
we should have done this
we shouldn't have done the show you've
been there for 47 years
and you left three and a half years ago
it's not like you left 30 years ago you
left three and a half years ago
and i only ran because of you joe
because if you and obama did a good job
i wouldn't have run i mean there would
have been no reason and if i did i
probably wouldn't have
been able to win so i only ran it's
quite it was quite insulting to him but
that's the way it is
biden had no plan no idea he didn't have
a clue he just wants to lock up
this country i mean he really does he's
going to lock it up if one
guy walks up and says sir i think we
should close up our country okay that
sounds good to me
while letting rioters and looters run
wild
or as joe calls them peaceful protesters
i call you protesters you know why
because there's a legal definition you
can't have a political rally they did
that to keep me out right
so i said oh i see you're protesters
the only thing you can do is protest
because they wanted to protect
anarchists rioters people that were
burning down your stores
so you have the absolute right to
protest so i call this a
friendly protest okay officially not a
rally
this is not a rally it's a friendly
protest okay now we've
gotten over the legal hurdle haven't we
believing whatever
gives them power whatever gives them
control
the biden plan will crush you and crush
your family
we will crush the virus and make our
success
make this country more successful
than it's ever been we have that kind of
potential we have the foundation set
you see what's happening you see the
kind of numbers we're doing
we're going to make our country more
successful
quickly than it's ever been when the
china plague arrived
we moved heaven and earth to fight the
disease we airlifted medical supplies
pioneered groundbreaking therapies
reduced the fatality rate
85 think of that 85 and now it's
actually higher than that
well here i am i mean i'm here right
i said give me that stuff whatever the
hell it is doctor i want it
the next day i woke up and i felt like
superman's right
i said get me the hell out of here i
have to go to wisconsin tonight
and saved over 2 million lives
our excess mortality rate has been 42
less than europe think of that 42 and
i'm working
and we're working with you very closely
look they have a problem we all
it should have never been allowed to
leave china
ever it should have never been allowed
it didn't go
once it got wuhan wuhan province
it never got out but it came to the usa
and europe and the rest of the world
i'm working to make the breakthrough
treatment i received
so what we're doing is we're going to
make the regeneron and eli lilly a great
company has a similar
antibody drug antibody drug
and we're going to make that available
to people that need it free
all i know is i didn't feel great and
after i took that i woke up the next
morning and i wanted
i tell you i felt like i could take on
the world i said let me at it
and here we are standing here freezing
thanks our relentless efforts 97
of all current emergency room visits are
for something other than the virus you
don't hear these numbers from the fake
news
think of that 97 and we're on track to
deliver 100 million doses of safe
vaccine and i say we're turning the
corner
we're turning the corner we're rounding
like this racetrack look at this it's
perfect
we're rounding the curve we will
vanquish the virus
and by the way we're going to have the
vaccine johnson and johnson
pfizer modern great companies and others
too
we have the vaccine we're going to have
it very soon like very soon we're going
to deliver
but without it also we're rounding the
curve we're rounding the corner
it's happening we're going to emerge
stronger than ever before
biden's made a corrupt bargain and the
democrats in exchange for his party's
nomination
he has handed control of his party over
to a rage
fill socialists and marxists and
left-wing extremists you see it you see
it in portland how about portland
we could solve that problem in i'd say a
half an hour
anarchists you know what happens to them
right
they go back home to mom and dad and
they also stay in the basement
that's what they have in common with
jill
well no joe when that one clip you know
that was yesterday that took place that
was what happened he was in the basement
he heard that we were doing really well
in pennsylvania which we are we're at
least two or three points up doesn't
sound like much you know what happens
with us
they'll say he's three points up and
then you win by like 10.
get a lot of hidden votes out there i
don't know if i'm supposed to be
complimented by that or not but they're
hidden votes
they don't want to talk see they are
they know what they are all
action right they call that all action
if biden wins the flag burning radicals
on the streets we'll be running for
you know that they'll be running your
government they'll be running your
government
this election day you must stop the
anti-american radicals
by delivering joe biden and those
far left democrats all democrats a
thundering defeat
this has to be a big defeat so we can
end it
just end it
and joe biden as you see is a corrupt
politician he wants to send you
jobs to china while his family rakes in
millions from the chinese communist
party
millions and he gets money from ukraine
he gets money from russia
how about ukraine his son sits on the
board
no energy experience no nothing didn't
have a job father becomes vice president
he becomes in charge of ukraine
sun goes on the board of barisma
goes on the border paris 183 000 a month
would you say that's good
would you say that's good if biden wins
china wins
china will own the usa if this happens
and they don't want me to win
they don't want me we charged them tens
of billions of dollars worth of tariffs
we never took 10 cents from china
and now we gave out where's hunter
he's going where's hunter where is
hunter by the way
come to think of it how about the laptop
from hell let's call the laptop right
now
and then you see shifty shift it was
russia that created the laptop ah
it was russia shifty shift
he stands it with a straight face
watermelon shape head like a water bow
it was russia i said oh no here we go
again
when we win you win wisconsin wins and
america wins that's what's going to
happen
we're joined today by members of
wisconsin manufacturers in commerce they
really helped us with this
location and you know we were going to
be out of the airport but the governor
made it very difficult so i said that's
all right get a location friendly people
and your states they really are your
state's chamber of commerce and i want
to thank them very much
where are you folks where are you guys
what a group of people
where where the hell are you i met you
there but there they are
good job you did thank you very much i
appreciate it
good job i said how are we doing they
said sir you're gonna win easy that's
pretty good they know the
they slightly know the area i'm thrilled
to receive
their first ever presidential
endorsement they've been around a long
time and they
gave us we've got a lot of endorsements
got a lot of newspaper endorsements
today too a lot of them
all over the country and every virtually
every law enforcement group has given us
the endorsement
even new york's finest they've never
endorsed a presidential candidate
and they want to be given back we've got
to respect our law enforcement we've got
to let him do what they have to do
also with us is candidate for congress
derek
van orden who's terrific where's derek
derek good luck i hear good things sarah
i hear good things derek van norden
please vote for him
when his competition is not good
not good and also state gop
chairman andrew hitt andrew thank you
are we winning andrew please if we don't
win we're going to fire you so fast
i hear good yeah just get out that vote
get out the vote
together we built the greatest economy
in history and now we're doing it again
make america great again again right
again again see all those hats
those hats are obsolete it's make
america great again again
we increased middle class family income
over six thousand dollars more
than five times the gains made under the
last
administration think of that in a short
period of time
african-american hispanic-american
asian-american unemployment
reached their lowest levels ever
recorded
since april we created a record 11.4
million jobs
i ended the nafta nightmare and proudly
signed
the brand new us mca into law
that's going to be a big deal just just
kicked in wisconsin dairy farms were
decimated under the obama
and biden nightmare they were decimated
and now
uh you are doing very well and you know
um
canada took advantage of you very much
you know that right
not anymore under the usmca our dairy
exports to canada
are expected to surge by at least 100
and we got rid of the tariffs you know
the tariffs you know they used to charge
you you didn't know this
you liked the song oh canada right yeah
hockey game
nice song oh canada the national anthem
right
by the way they stand for our
nationalism our people have to stand for
our national anthem
they have to stay but canada treated us
badly 287 percent
tariff can you believe that think of it
i learned about that i said it's time to
get out of that crazy nafta nafta was a
terrible thing
when gm went bankrupt biden and obama
threw the workers of delphi
corporation to the wolves their pensions
were wiped out i signed an order to
restore the pensions of
delphi and others and health care
benefits promised the workers
and these are workers in michigan ohio
and wisconsin that got
really promised a lot of things and it
never happened we took care of it
i will never let anyone rip off our
great american worker
they were treated very badly with a lot
of promises from
biden and obama under my by the way do
you see this you see the people they get
for the crowds
obama was up he he drew flies today
flies
we drew nobody they had caught you know
the cars are honking right honk hong
kong
let's go home i never saw anything like
this they have cars
they have like 12 cars now they have
circles they have bigger circles for
cars together
i never saw anything like it obama has
no crowd
i thought he had like a crowd right he
doesn't have anything
the only one that has smaller crowds is
sleepy joe biden he's got
nobody and the press doesn't like
covering our crowds we have the opposite
we have so many people they don't like
it
but they never show they never
show that nobody joe was speaking
yesterday there was nobody there before
they carried him off the stage
think of it he got nervous speaking to
nobody
but that wasn't nervous that was another
problem under my leadership
we achieved the most secure border in
u.s history
my opponent's insane immigration plan
completely eliminates u.s borders
by implementing nationwide catch and
release
he would make every you know that is you
catch a criminal murderer rapist you
catch him and you have to release him
into the united states
then within two or three years they're
supposed to come back for a trial we had
an argument during the debate
i said sleepy joe they don't come back
yes i do
they proudly come back no no joe they're
murderers
they don't come back joe i turned out to
be right but you know
he would make every community into a
sanctuary city for violent criminals
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s military
you know that right you were a big
beneficiary
a lot of business in this state
including nearly
six billion dollars to save the historic
shipyard
marinette marine you know that right and
they're great i was there
four or five months ago i was watching
they built beautiful beautiful looks
like a yacht with lots of weapons on it
the only difference is you got rockets
all over the damn thing but it is
beautiful
we killed the leader of isis al baghdadi
we took out the world's number one
terrorist solomani is dead
we took out 100 of the isis caliphate
also
when i took over when i took over it was
a
mess i withdrew from the last
administration's
disastrous iran nuclear deal 150 billion
dollars 1.8
billion in cash you know we got nothing
i recognize the true capital of israel
and opened the american
embassy in jerusalem
and instead of never-ending wars we are
forging peace in the middle east we're
doing it it's like
it's like working out really well three
countries already
and many are lined up they're all
wanting to get in a vote for republicans
is a vote
for the american dream we are the party
of abraham lincoln
it's a vote for the american group and
in conclusion over the next four years
we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all it's already happening
we will make our medical supplies right
here in the united states
right here in wisconsin
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary
cities you don't want the sanctuary
we will defend the right to life
religious liberty
free speech and the right to keep and
bear arms
it's very important supreme court you
got to do that you got to remember a lot
of people think that's why i got elected
because of the supreme court
and we've got already three great
justices
amy yesterday
and by the end of the first term we'll
have close to three maybe more
but approximately 300 federal judges
including court of appeals judges
the record it's a record we will
maintain america's unrivaled military
might and we will ensure peace
through strength so the two and a half
trillion dollars
the greatest rockets and missiles
hydrosonic
the greatest in the world they go seven
times faster than
what we have today we have tanks we have
planes we have bombers we have
submarines
we've rebuilt our military we have the
greatest
we have the greatest equipment the
greatest
military force in the world russia
china everybody they are envious
nobody thought we could do this and
we've done it all
it's a lot of it's made right here but
all made
in the usa all made in the usa
our nuclear is now in tippy top shape
and
just hope just hope that we never have
to use it that's all
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency already signed
january 1st it goes into effect
lower drug prices even further favored
nations nobody can believe i did it
we're going to get the lowest prices in
the world
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states will be the
first nation to land an astronaut
on mars and nasa right now is the
talk of the world as a space center
again
it was closed and a mess when i took
over we will stop the radical
indoctrination of our students and
restore
patriotic education to our school
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect our
great
american flag and we will live by the
timeless words of our national motto
in god we trust right
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
wisconsin that's what we're doing
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors get your co-workers even
grab your boss if you have to
come on boss you got to go out and get
out and vote you got to get out and well
got to get out this is a thing you got
to do just remember
the grey red wave
[Applause]
it's now just starting to form it's and
they know it's coming
they know it's coming we didn't come
this far
and fight this hard to surrender our
country back
to the corrupt washington swamp on
november 3rd we must finish the job
drain the swamp go out and vote can be
before november 3rd
go out and vote from green bay to la
crosse
from madison to milwaukee and from
janesville to right here in west salem
we inherit the legacy of red-blooded
american patriots
who poured out their hearts sweat and
soul to secure our liberty
and defend our freedom we stand on the
shoulders of american heroes who crossed
the oceans
settled the continent tamed the
wilderness
laid down the railroads raised up the
great skyscrapers
won two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and made america the single greatest
nation
in the history of the world and the best
is yet to come
[Applause]
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning
[Music]
[Applause]
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of wisconsin
we have made america powerful again
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you wisconsin thank
you very much
get out and vote thank you very much
[Music]
cause you're in a new town
anyway
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
are you listening to me
[Music]
but you've got to know this
one thing no man does it all by himself
put your pride on the shelf and just go
down
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can hang out with all the boys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
pick yourself off the ground
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you
myself
[Music]
blue
[Music]
for the band
pretty eye
pirate smile
[Music]
you marry music man
[Music]
by lorena you must
have seen her
[Music]
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
[Music]
jesus freak
out in the street
and then tickets are